erklären weil in den letzten tagen hat
ihre partei gleich zwei landtagswahlen
krachend verloren ist das ein problem
auf landesebene oder ist das nicht eher
1 auf bundesebene das ist etwas was uns
als spd insgesamt beschäftigt wir haben
drei landtagswahlen jetzt gehabt in
diesem jahr drei landtagswahlen nach der
erfolgreichen bundestagswahl wir haben
im saarland die absolute mehrheit geholt
aber wir hatten in schleswig holstein
und auch in nordrhein-westfalen höhere
ansprüche wir wollten dort besser
abschneiden wir hatten uns vorgenommen
dort künftig den ministerpräsidenten zu
stellen und jetzt sehen wir in schleswig
holstein hat es nicht geklappt da werden
die koalitionsverhandlung jetzt woanders
geführt und für nordrhein-westfalen muss
man klar sagen herr wüst ist mit der cdu
stärkste kraft geworden er hat jetzt
erst mal die aufgabe gespräche zu führen
und dann gucken wir ob das funktioniert
aber ich sage für uns auch ganz klar wir
stehen bereit verantwortung zu
übernehmen falls herr wüst keine
regierung bilden kann klingbeil das hört
sich ganz anders an als das was ihre
generalsekretär am abend der wahl am
sonntag abend verbreitet hat lassen sie
uns doch einmal ganz kurz reinhören
zusammen
kevin jetzt geht es darum dass hendrik
wüst in einem nächsten schritt gespräche
für eine neue regierung führen wird was
aber auch klar geworden ist und das
haben wir gestern abend gesagt ist dass
die spd bereit steht verantwortung zu
übernehmen nordrhein-westfalen dass wir
bereit stehen das umzusetzen wofür wir
mit thomas kutschaty an der spitze im
wahlkampf geworben haben das war nun sie
werden es bemerkt haben wir noch nicht
gerade das war der parteivorsitzende
persönlich nämlich sieht aber der tenor
ist ja derselbe also am abend der wahl
haben sie herr kühn und noch sehr sehr
viel stärker und drastischer daran
festgehalten dass sie eigentlich gar
nicht die verlierer sind sondern das ist
eine aufgabe gebe die regierung zu
bilden womöglich in einer art mini ampel
im land herr wenn sie das machen wenn
doch der wählerwille so klar ist
schwarz-grün er wurde das stimmt ja auch
so nicht das erste was ich in diesem
statement das sie gerade eingeblendet
tagen getan habe ist dass ich herrn wüst
und der cdu in nordrhein-westfalen
gratuliert habe aber ich sage ihnen auch
mit der erfahrung die ich jetzt nach
fairen generalsekretär habe und mit auch
unsicherheiten die da sind gerade in der
pandemie wo ja viele per brief wählen wo
häufig die institute auch falsch gelegen
haben mit den zahlen die man um 18 uhr
hatte da muss man den wahlen schon
bisschen abwarten und auch das habe ich
in diesem statement gesagt es hat sich
im laufe des abends gezeigt dass der
abstand zwischen spd und cdu immer
größer wurde deswegen habe ich im laufe
des abends auch sehr klar gemacht wer
auf platz eins ist und wer das recht auf
die ersten verhandlungen hat aber ich
habe zum beispiel bei der berlin wahl
erlebt als es um die frage gehen ob
franziska gefallen bürgermeisterin wird
dass die spd in den ersten prognosen um
18 uhr hinter anderen parteien lag und
sich dann im laufe des abends vorbei
geschoben hat und deswegen ist es gut
wenn man wartet bis doch mindestens eine
mehrzahl der stimmen ausgezählt ist aber
noch mal klar ist die union verhandelt
jetzt wir haben gratuliert wenn man die
bundestagswahl zurückdenkt dann hat das
bei herrn laschet ja sehr lange gedauert
bis der olaf scholz gratuliert hatte hat
die bild ja auch ein bisschen
mitgeholfen durch den politischen druck
dass herr laschet danach glaubt 34 tagen
erstmals olaf scholz gratuliert hat
alles das haben wir nicht gemacht wir
haben gratuliert wir haben gesagt wird
das recht hat zu verhandeln aber ob das
klappt das er wüst einen regierungen
bekommt das entscheidet nicht die spd
das entscheiden jetzt jähnigen wieder
verhandeln aber der wählerwille ist eben
sehr klar und die eigene generalsekretär
hat das nicht ganz so vornehm gemacht
wie sie vielleicht schauen wir uns
dessen statement noch mal ganz kurz an
[Applaus]
gucken noch mal ganz kurz in das
statement von spd-generalsekretär kevin
kühnert am abend der wahl
okay und ich höre gerade das dauert noch
ein paar sekunden bis die regie das
vorhalten kann wie dem auch sei es gab
stimmen in ihrer partei die haben sich
doch dem sieger gefühlt oder dem sieg
mehr gefühlt als der niederlage das hat
glaube ich die einen oder anderen wähler
verschreckt auch intern gab es kritik
ihr vorgänger norbert walter borjans hat
gesagt es sei nun gewiss nicht der
moment in dem man die backen auf postern
könne hätten sie nicht besser mal auf
ihn gehört oder ihre partei also ich
habe beschrieben wie die entwicklung
auch von dem statement von kevin kühnert
kurz nach 18 uhr war dann laufe des
abends sage ich ja auch wer anne will
gesehen hat hat gesehen dass ich dort
auch klar gemacht hat wie die linie ist
die habe ich hier gerade vertreten und
das ist eine linie eines fairen
zweitplatzierten der ganz klar an
erkennt wer die wahl gewonnen hat und
das sind die grünen und die cdu und
jetzt muss man gucken wie gespräche
miteinander geführt werden und das ist
übrigens auch das was herr wüst ja
deutlich gemacht hat dass alle
demokratischen parteien miteinander
reden was die grünen klar gesagt haben
die fdp und auch wir das gehört zur
demokratie dazu es müssen sich jetzt
regierung bilden aber natürlich muss die
spd gucken und damit waren wir gestern
in den gremien beschäftigt wie kann es
sein dass drei vier tage vor der wahl
drei vier tage vor der wahl auch die
medien noch von einem
kopf-an-kopf-rennen reden auch die
institute ein kopf an kopf rennen sehen
und am ende der unterschied bei neun
prozent liegt also was ist da eigentlich
passiert was kann man nicht mal besser
machen natürlich treibt uns dass partei
und das ist ja auch mein anspruch als
parteivorsitzender dass wir besser
werden und deswegen muss man jetzt
konsequenzen ziehen aus diesem
wahlergebnis her klingt weil es gibt
auch stimmen die sagen da ist gar nichts
passiert sondern sie haben jetzt einfach
das ergebnis bekommen dass sie auch in
der bundestagswahl bekommen hätten hätte
die cdu nicht mit dem spitzenkandidat
armin laschet und nach der desaströsen
unterstützung durch angela merkel einen
der schlechtesten wahlkämpfer aller
zeiten in diesem land hingelegt
vereinfacht gesagt die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesem land so die meinung von
vielen wollen schwarz grün braucht es
die spd eigentlich noch wenn sie
dermaßen drastisch abrutschten minus 4,6
prozent in nrw - 11,3 prozent in
schleswig holstein ist die volkspartei
zeit nicht einfach zu ende für sie ein
parteivorsitzender einer partei die in
der hälfte aller bundesländer
ministerpräsident stellt vier männer
vier frauen das sind 8 in der summe es
gibt keine partei die so viele
ministerpräsidenten hat ich bin
vorsitzender einer partei die den
bundeskanzler stellt und nachdem niemand
uns geglaubt hat dass für diese
bundestagswahl gewinnen können haben wir
es geschafft am ende vorne zu liegen
eine ampel regierung erstmals in der
geschichte dieses landes zu bilden ich
habe gerade gesagt wir haben nach der
bundestagswahl erfolgreich die absolute
mehrheit im saarland geholt und ich will
daran erinnern dass auch ein
bundespräsident der ja das spd
parteibuch das ruht jetzt gerade aber
frank walter steinmeier gehört zur
sozialdemokratischen familie also so
schlecht steht die spd gar nicht da und
das sage ich jetzt nicht mit
triumphgeheul weil ich weiß dass eine
wahl in schleswig holstein eine wahl in
nordrhein-westfalen natürlich tut das
weh natürlich ist das nicht das ergebnis
das ich mir gewünscht hätte natürlich
müssen wir aufarbeiten was da passiert
ist aber wissen sehr wohl ich erlebe
immer dass in dem moment wo die spd
gewinnt da ist das ein zufall dass das
ein unfall da ist dass die schwäche der
anderen
und in dem moment wo die spd nicht so
gut abschneidet da reiht sich das einen
den niedergang der deutschen
sozialdemokratie und wenn ich auf die
reinen fakten gucken muss ich sagen
diese geschichte stimmt nicht die spd
wird gebraucht die spd hat eine wichtige
verantwortung in diesem land und diese
verantwortung nehmen wir wahr und freuen
uns dass sie den bundeskanzler stellen
aber in der heutigen insa umfrage die
sie in bild finden spüren sie auch schon
den atem der grünen im nacken die ja nun
sehr stark geworden sind in nrw haben
sie das ergebnis verdreifacht und auf
bundesebene jetzt in der umfrage nur
noch einen prozentpunkt hinter der spd
werden sie eigentlich von bell book &
harbeck die ja auch einen unglaublichen
wandel hingelegt haben und ich glaube
ich wirklich größter beliebtheit in der
bevölkerung erfreuen überholt werden
erst mal liegen wir gerade vorne und wir
haben jetzt eine dynamik in den umfragen
das ist in der tat so wir haben auch
gesehen dass es jetzt nordrhein
westfalen ein gutes ergebnis der grünen
gibt auch in schleswig holstein dazu
gratuliere ich auch ich finde das ist
auch wichtig war dass wir kein wahlkampf
gemacht haben wo wir als
koalitionspartner im bund auf die
anderen draufhauen das haben wir bewusst
auch gesagt wir wollen in der ampel in
berlin gut zusammen regieren ich finde
auch da muss man muss man vernünftig
miteinander umgehen deswegen haben wir
in nordrhein westfalen kein wahlkampf
gegeneinander geführt
ich habe ein interesse an einer starken
spd daran arbeite ich und ich verstehe
dass fdp und grüne daran arbeiten sie
stark sind aber das entscheidende ist
dass wir in der ampel in berlin dass wir
da die wichtigen aufgaben angehen wir
haben einen krieg zu bewältigen wir
müssen das land durch einen brutalen
krieg von wladimir putin durchbringen
wir haben die großen
transformationsprozesse der umbau der
wirtschaft die klimaneutralität der
soziale zusammenhalt das sind herkules
aufgaben die wir zu meistern haben und
deswegen brauchen wir zusammenhalt in
der koalition in der ampel und da
sollten wir nicht die ganze zeit auch
die anderen parteien als konkurrenz
betrachten sondern als partner sollten
wir uns begreifen und das muss auch der
stil in dieser koalition sein wie wir
das ja in den koalitionsverhandlungen
begonnen haben er klingelt sie sprechen
die enormen herausforderungen auf
bundesebene für das gesamte land an und
nun stellen sie ja auch den
bundeskanzler oft ist es so dass eine
partei daneben auch den kanzlerbonus
verspürt das war bei vielen
landtagswahlen so als angela merkel
bundeskanzlerin war der kanzlerbonus
scheint komplett aufgebraucht zu sein
haben sie nicht den eindruck also wenn
ich auf die letzten neuen landtagswahlen
kuka hat die spd davon sechs gewonnen da
sehe ich jetzt rückblickend nicht so
unbedingt den merkel bonus den sie
gerade ansprechen und wenn ich auf
saarland gucke da war olaf scholz
genauso unterwegs wie in nordrhein
westfalen wo es hat leider nicht
geklappt hat olaf stolz olaf scholz ist
eine starke führungsperson er hat die
bundestagswahl gewonnen hatte die
mehrheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
überzeugt aber ja wir sind gerade in
schwierigen phasen für dieses land es
sind schwierige entscheidungen die der
bundeskanzler die die regierung zu
treffen hat da habe ich respekt vor
diesen entscheidungen die getroffen
werden aber ich sage ihnen auch dass wir
im wahlkampf bewusst geworden ist in
vielen gesprächen dass diese
bundesregierung gerade die richtigen
entscheidungen trifft wenn es
beispielsweise um den krieg geht wenn es
um die frage auch geht der
transformation oder den sozialen
zusammenhalt den wir stärken wollen in
diesem land und darüber reden wir sicher
gleich noch über den krieg ich möchte
nur noch einmal sagen die letzten jahre
von angela merkel sind für den
kanzlerbonus aus berlin vielleicht gar
nicht so entscheidend gewesen wie ihre
frühen jahre was man jedenfalls bei den
grünen in nordrhein-westfalen gemerkt
hat und auch in schleswig holstein ist
dass die auf jeden fall den vizekanzler
bonus haben oder eben den großen
rückhalt aus berlin die großen
begeisterungsstürme
die es für das spitzenpersonal der
partei gerade in der bevölkerung gibt
was man ja auch kritisch sehen kann
warum ist das bei der spd nicht so warum
kommt das nicht an sie sei der kanzler
trifft die richtigen entscheidungen in
der krise aber es scheint ja nicht zu
verfangen was macht er also falsch wir
haben der auswertung der wahl in
nordrhein-westfalen gesehen dass wir ein
großes problem hat man als spd also ich
glaube auch ein problem insgesamt als
demokratische parteien es ist der
gestiegene anteil der nichtwähler die
wahlbeteiligung lag nur noch bei 55
prozent ich finde das ist dramatisch
dass so viele menschen und sich der wahl
nicht mehr an der wahl beteiligen und
wir sehen gerade in den auswertungen der
zahlen dass viele die vorher spd gewählt
haben nämlich 300.000 menschen uns nicht
mehr gewählt haben und die befragung
zeigt dass einer der wesentlichen gründe
ist dass sie sagen ihr habt nicht
gesehen welche probleme wir haben welche
herausforderungen im lebensalltag haben
und das sind gesteigen gestiegene preise
das ist inflation das sind energiepreise
das ist ein thema wo wir faktisch ja
viel gemacht haben sogar in der
bundesregierung zwei entlastungspaket
über 30 milliarden entlastung den
mindestlohn jetzt auf den weg gebracht
bafög reform also wo es auch noch mal
darum geht studierende zu stärken wir
haben jetzt die größte rentenerhöhung
zum ersten siebten also das sind ja
alles sachen die den menschen den rücken
stärken aber wir haben es nicht
geschafft und das muss man
selbstkritisch sagen
diese konkrete regierungspolitik die
erfolgt und die gutes für die menschen
im land die konkret entlastet die so zu
kommunizieren dass sie bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ankommt dass sie
wahrgenommen wird und dass am ende auch
gesagt wird ist es gut dass die
sozialdemokratie regiert und dass sie
etwas für die menschen hier tut und das
ist eine herausforderung vor der
bestehen
und das beschäftigt mich auch seitdem
ich die zahlen gesehen habe und glaube
dass wir hier eine eine andere
kommunikation brauchen herking weil sie
sagen es selbst es ist vielleicht nicht
immer gelungen die
sozialdemokratische politik den menschen
zu vermitteln und es richtig zu
kommunizieren und ich glaube ein thema
treibt die bürgerinnen und bürger in
deutschland ganz besonders um nämlich
der krieg der brutale angriffskrieg von
wladimir putin aus unserer sicht
anlasslos auf die ukraine voll drogen
mord und natürlich auch immer wieder
drohungen gegen den westen es gibt nun
sehr viele staatschefs und sehr viele
länder die eine weitaus klare haltung
dem konflikt gegenüber haben als der
deutsche bundeskanzler es gibt selbst in
der deutschen bundesregierung
politikerinnen und politiker die eine
viel klarere haltung haben zb die
außenministerin
warum kommt dass das olaf scholz es
selbst hier nicht schafft eine klare
gradlinige sprache zu finden sondern das
was ja viele auch für ihn typische
empfinden seit seiner zeit als hamburger
bürgermeister sich in floskeln er geht
und die klaren antworten dem land und
der bevölkerung eigentlich schuldig
bleibt also die bundesregierung hat eine
klare linie ich habe mich erst in der
letzten woche mit dem ukrainischen
außenminister persönlich getroffen ich
will jetzt gar nicht auf die
gesprächsinhalte gehen weil wir
verabredet haben das ist ein
vertrauliches gespräch ist aber uns
danach auch vor die presse gestellt und
er hat sich bei deutschland bedankt für
die umfassende hilfe hat gesagt
deutschland ist mittlerweile eines der
führenden länder was die unterstützung
angeht wenn nicht sogar das führende
land in europa was die unterstützung in
unterschiedlichen facetten finanziell
militärisch auch was das politische
angeht also ich glaube dass wir einen
sehr klaren kurs haben in der
bundesregierung und wissen sie es gibt
ja nicht die bundesregierung von
annalena baerbock oder die von christian
lindner oder die von olaf scholz es gibt
eine bundesregierung die dinge sind
abgesprochen die sind abgestimmt
miteinander und das ist das was ich für
richtig halte auch dass wir uns sowohl
in der koalition aber auch international
abstimmen dass wir auch durchdacht die
schritte gehen aber wir liefern waffen
das ist ein bruch mit bisheriger
deutscher außen- und sicherheitspolitik
wir sind schon vor kriegsbeginn die
kraft gewesen in europa die ganz viel
finanzielle unterstützung für die
ukraine gibt wir sind die politische
kraft die grad in europa aber auch mit
joe biden mit dem transatlantischen
bündnis die koordiniert dass wir
geschlossen vorgehen und bei den
sanktionspaket wissen sie auch haben wir
sechs auf den weg gebracht und das sind
sehr umfassende sanktionen die russland
gerade ins mark treffen also das ist ein
vorgehen der bundesregierung dass ich
für richtig halte und das von olaf
scholz an der spielzug uriniert
verklagen weil das kann ich so nicht
stehen lassen nach ihrem treffen war
herr kleber der ukrainische
außenminister auch hier im studio wir
standen an dem studio tisch der gerade
rechts von uns platziert ist und er auch
er berichtete mir in seinen
diplomatischen worten dass er
deutschland dankbar sei wie es aber auch
drastisch darauf hin und zwar mehrfach
dass ihn der bundeskanzler kurz
empfangen habe ein kurzes get together
wohingegen annalena baerbock von seinem
präsidenten von präsident selent ski in
kiew nur stunden hinweg empfangen und
betreut worden sei und dass er ist ja
ein großer diplomat herr kollege und er
bleibt natürlich im diplomatischen ton
aber es war doch deutlich erkennbar dass
ihnen die treffen in deutschland nicht
ausgereicht haben und dass er ist dies
nun ausdrücklich meine interpretation
die aber mir doch sehr offensichtlich
erschien es fast als affront
wahrgenommen hat dass der bundeskanzler
für ihn keine zeit oder fast keine zeit
gefunden hat in einem zu einem zeitpunkt
da in der ukraine ja auch die deutschen
werte die werte des westens mit
verteidigt werden sie interpretieren das
ist ihr gutes recht ich kann ihnen nur
sagen was die inhalte unseres gespräches
waren und da will ich jetzt noch mal
nicht in das vertrauliche detail gehen
sondern kann nur darauf hinweisen dass
wir ein öffentliches statement hatten
olaf scholz ist ist in vielfältiger art
und weise mit der ukrainischen regierung
mit herrn selensky auch im gespräch das
wird ja auch immer öffentlich wenn die
beiden sich absprechen wenn sie
telefonieren wenn sie dann auch
politisch sich austauschen also und noch
mal es gibt glaube ich kein land in
europa das so stark sich auch an die
seite der ukraine stellt was finanzielle
hilfen was waffenlieferungen was den
politischen druck angeht was das
vorbereiten und das durchhalten von
sanktionen angeht also da machen wir
sehr viel und wir sind jeden tag auch
dabei zu prüfen was können wir noch mehr
noch herr kleber sie hatten in ihrer
vorherigen antwort auch gesagt dass ihre
partei schon immer für einen klaren kurs
steht oder es zumindest zu angedeutet
auch das halte ich für vollkommen falsch
wie können sie das behaupten frau
schwesig hat diese umstrittene pipeline
zu ende gebaut hat eine stiftung
gegründet getarnt als umweltstiftung wie
man heute weiß die nur dazu da war die
amerikanischen sanktionen zu unterlaufen
sie haben mit wladimir putin einen
menschen der einerseits zwar altkanzler
andererseits aber gas lobbyist und ein
freund das ja man muss es heute sagen
massenmörders und diktators putins ist
den sie aus ihrer partei entweder nicht
raus haben wollen oder nicht
rausbekommen sie haben auch noch viel
anderes personal aus den letzten
legislaturperioden perioden aber bis
auch in die gegenwart reichen leute die
putin ein großes verständnis gegenüber
bringen die wir schröder teilweise mit
ihm befreundet senders er bildet das
sich an die spitze es ist doch nun
wirklich nicht so dass sie über ihre
partei sagen können das sei die partei
immer mit dem klaren transatlantischen
kurs gewesen eigentlich in ruhe ich mich
schon richtig zitieren ich habe gesagt
das gilt für diese bundesregierung und
olaf scholz ist seit start dieser
regierung sehr klar es ist sehr klar
dass sanktionen vorbereitet wurden schon
vor dem 24 februar das wissen sie auch
dass olaf scholz von tag eins dran
gearbeitet hat sich im transatlantischen
und europäischen bündnis abgestimmt hat
wir hatten alle gehofft dass dieser
krieg nicht kommt aber wir waren darauf
vorbereitet dass wenn er kommt dass wir
dann sehr schnell sehr umfassend sehr
konsequent reagieren und das hat damit
zu tun dass olaf scholz das vorbereitet
hat die punkte die sie ansprechen sind
ja dinge die wir aufarbeiten in aller
klarheit auch ich habe das öffentlich
gesagt dass wir uns sehr genau mit der
frage beschäftigen müssen warum nicht
nur die spd sondern die deutsche politik
insgesamt warum wir zu lange an einem
guten verhältnis zu wladimir putin
festgehalten haben warum wir nicht 2008
der krieg gegen georgien 2014 die
völkerrechtswidrige aktion der krim die
wir verurteilt haben aber nicht in
meiner sicht aus heute weitreichende
konsequenzen gezogen haben tiergarten
mord nav allen die das waren alles
zeichen wo man anders hätte abbiegen
müssen und insofern ist es ein
politischer konsens in diesem land
gewesen dass wir billiges russisches gas
billiges russisches öl wollen das ist ja
nicht die spd sondern das war die
gesellschaft insgesamt wir hatten 16
jahre eine cdu kanzlerin die das auch
vorangetrieben hat aber natürlich sie
haben recht wir müssen uns kritisch
fragen an welchen stellen hätte man
anders abbiegen müssen wo hätte man
anders handeln müssen und das finde ich
übrigens wichtig dass wir das klären
auch wichtig dass wir das klären für
zukünftige politik weil ich glaube dass
wir jetzt gerade das stoppschild setzen
müssen dass wir nicht mit china in eine
nächste abhängigkeit geraten und wir
dann beide vielleicht hier in zehn
jahren stehen und sagen hätte man mal
damals richtig gehandelt ich glaube wir
müssen sehr stark und es mit der frage
beschäftigen wie konnte es passieren
dass wir eine solche energiepolitische
abhängigkeit mit russland geraten sind
dass wir mit einem system wo wir gesehen
haben wie die politischen
fehlentwicklungen sind trotzdem weiter
dieses bündnis hatten und ich möchte
dass wir das so aufarbeiten dass vor
allem die konsequenz daraus gezogen wird
für die zukunft dass so etwas nie wieder
passieren kann und was das
transatlantische angeht aber das will
ich noch sagen
die zeit für ein transatlantisches
bündnis und die wiederbelebung eines
transatlantischen bündnisses war glaube
ich lange nicht so gut wie gerade gerade
ist das ganze getrieben von wladimir
putin weil wir uns gegen den krieg wären
aber ich wünsche mir dass wir auch
darüber hinaus als europäer als
amerikaner als deutsch amerikaner dass
wir zusammenstehen und die chance dieser
zeit ergreifen dass wir auf den weg
bringen wie die digitalisierung
gestaltet werden kann wie handel
gestaltet werden kann wie
sicherheitspolitik gemeinsam gestaltet
werden kann also die revitalisierung des
transatlantischen bündnisses teams genau
jetzt kommen er klingt weil sie loben
den klaren kurs der bundesregierung
unter ihrem bundeskanzler olaf scholz
gilt das eigentlich auch für die
verteidigungsministerien die ebenfalls
aus ihrer partei kommt christine
lambrecht sie hat zu beginn des krieges
gar keine klare haltung gehabt sondern
hat gesagt dass eigentlich schwere
waffenlieferungen oder waffenlieferungen
insgesamt gar nicht möglich sein sie
hatte kannte offensichtlich auch ihr
haus nicht wusste nicht welche
lagerbestände vorhanden sind was
deutschland überhaupt schicken könnte
das hat sich nun ein bisschen geändert
aber man hat ja nun erstens und ich
fasse zwei fragen zusammen überhaupt
nicht
das gefühl dass ramprecht die treibende
kraft hinter der politik ist die sie
wahrnehmen die sie skizzieren nämlich
hilfe für die ukraine ein ganz klarer
kompass und zweitens steht ja frau
lamprecht auch ansonsten noch massiv
unter druck finden sie dass meine zweite
frage angemessen mit dem sohn mal eben
in die nähe von suhl zu fliegen auf den
bundeswehrstützpunkt bei dem gar nicht
so richtig viel passiert und dann noch
ein bisschen urlaub hinten dran zu
hängen also punkt eins ich habe vor
lamprecht sehr entschieden wahrgenommen
in der ganzen frage unterstützung der
ukraine aber natürlich muss eine
verteidigungsministerin sich überblick
verschaffen welche waffen können
geliefert werden es ist ja auch kein
geheimnis dass gerade in den letzten
jahren haben die bundeswehr sehr
runtergewirtschaftet wurde deswegen
werden wir jetzt sondervermögen mit 100
milliarden auf den weg bringen hoffen
dass wir da einen konsens auch mit der
union erzielen dass wir den soldatinnen
und soldaten den rücken stärken aber
erinnern sie sich an 2011 als jetzt zu
guttenberg verteidigungsminister war und
gesagt hat die haushaltskonsolidierung
ist das strategische parameter auch der
bundeswehrreform als wir ich gehe jetzt
ins detail ich bin ihr
verteidigungspolitiker über sowas wie
dynamisches verfügbarkeit management
also schöne begriffe was am ende aber
hieß das ja zu guttenberg darauf abzielt
dass nur noch 70 auch der geräte da sind
ja man hat aus wege versucht rhetorische
tricks versucht zu finden wie man das
rechtfertigen konnte dass kein geld für
die bundeswehr da ist und damit müssen
wir heute leben aber wir wollen das
jetzt ändern aber natürlich musste die
ministerin erst mal gucken was ist
überhaupt möglich was kann geliefert
werden und wir liefern deutschland
liefert deutschland liefert viele waffen
und insofern ist
die kritik die sie gerade formuliert
haben auch nicht richtig weil man im
laufe der zeit sieht wie es immer mehr
wurde auch international abgestimmt auch
mittlerweile ja schweres gerät und zum
zweiten punkt will ich ihn klar sagen es
gibt vorschriften an die haben sich
ministerin und minister zu halten diese
vorschriften hart frau lamprecht
eingehalten und das ministerium minister
urlaub machen seines drei tage oder 4
tage das halte ich für legitim und das
söhne im bundeswehr-hubschrauber
mitfliegen halten sie nicht nur der
vorschrift nach sondern auch es gibt ja
auch dass beim begriff der amts wurde
und der anscheins vermeidung was ja vor
bereiche sind zu einem tatsächlichen
verstoß das finden sie also auch in
dieser hinsicht nicht nur in der rein
juristisch legalistischen hinsicht
angemessen ich finde erst mal dass die
messlatte für ministerin minister sind
genau die vorschriften ist das
juristische ich keine andere minister
auch aus der union die ihre frauen mit
dabei hatten wenn es zum auslandsreisen
gingen auch das ist ja nie hinterfragt
worden insofern gibt es dort eine praxis
noch mal die rechtlich einwandfrei ist
die rechtlich geklärt ist und insofern
ist das dann für mich auch in ordnung
wenn frau lambrecht es so macht für
viele andere in ihrer partei nicht dass
es meine letzte frage herr klingbeil
kutschaty der spitzenkandidat in nrw der
gerade verloren hat hat auf die frage
geantwortet wie er zu dem ganzen skandal
oder möglichen skandal um die
verteidigungsministerin stünde und was
das mit seiner wahlniederlage zu tun hat
genützt hat das gegen falls nicht können
sie diese lakonische äußerungen
nachvollziehen
ärgern sie sich auch über frau lamprecht
ich hab grad schon deutlich gemacht dass
ich vor allem glaube dass der hauptgrund
warum wir nordrhein westfalen so viele
menschen verloren haben ins
nichtwählerlager darin liegt dass wir es
nicht geschafft haben die politik die
wir auf bundesebene durchgesetzt haben
wenn es darum geht pendlern unter die
arme zu greifen wenn es darum geht
familien in der krise zu stärken
transferleistungsempfänger aber vor
allem die arbeitende bevölkerung die
gerade von inflation von höheren
lebensmittelpreisen von höheren
spritpreisen getroffen ist dass wir für
die ordentlich festgemacht haben da
müssen wir uns an die eigene nase fassen
und sagen warum haben wir es nicht
geschafft dass deutlicher zu
kommunizieren rüberzubringen dass die
menschen wie übrigens bei der
bundestagswahl in klaren einfachen
verständlichen sätzen sehen das macht
die spd für sie das ist jetzt die
aufgabe und das müssen wir gemeinsam als
spd leisten und da sind alle in der
verantwortung alles klar lieber herr
klingbeil spd parteivorsitzender heute
bei bild tv im studio vielen dank dass
sie da waren sehr gerne